dans le château de dampierre aujourd'hui
vide pour travaux se trouvait une
duchesse là haut
son visage est toujours présent sur les
murs au dessus d'une porte le portrait
de marie aimée d'euros en duchesse de
chevreuse que seul un historien averti
peut reconnaître nez avec son siècle en
1600 mari et mes deux romans arrive à
ses 17 ans à la cour de louis xiii et
d'anne d'autriche où elle fait sensation
à 18 ans elle était sur un tante d'anne
d'autriche
pour vous donner une idée l'importance
du poste de surintendant elle commandait
environ 600 personnes
inutile de vous dire qu'elle faisait des
envieux et ce qu'elle avait à l'a20
privilège qui était très couru chez les
grandes dames et les grandes familles
c'est qu'elle avait ce qu'on appelle le
droit du tabouret ou du carreau
c'est à dire que c'était seuls ces
princesses de grands noms avaient le
encore un privilège de pouvoir s'asseoir
en présence de la famille royale et ces
dames se battait pour avoir le privilège
du chaos ou du tabouret la reine de
france restera son ami viendra même la
visite et à dampierre le château dans
lequel elle passera du temps avec son
second mariage avec claude de lorraine
mais marie deroo ont été surtout une
femme qui plaisait aux hommes ce qu'il
faut savoir à en regardant ses yeux qui
sont quand même extrêmement évocateur
c'est richelieu qu'il l'avait surnommée
la chevrette
c'était bien normal puisqu'elle était
duchesse de cheuvreux elle était réputée
très délurée très coquine très
intelligente très belle et donc on l'a
ici on voit bien qu'elle a un petit côté
j'allais dire sarcastique c'est pas tout
à fait de qualificatifs mais on sent que
l un regard qui vous fouilles de
l'angleterre à l'espagne tous succombé à
ses charmes ton assez habilement joué
depuis son hôtel de chevreuse rue saint
thomas du louvre à paris c'était
complètement une femme politique c'est à
dire que les ministres les deux
ministres successifs les deux cardinaux
successifs s'en référer à ce concours
une pensée on l'aménagé on l'a on la
questionner particulièrement stratège la
duchesse s'attirer les foudres des
puissants qui n'hésitait pas à l'envoyer
régulièrement en exil 12 ans de sa vie
cumulés certains de ces exils consistait
à rester au château de dampierre dans
lequel elle n'était pas enfermé bien
longtemps elle partait par la porte
rouge qui se trouvait derrière ces
pavillons elle se déguise en homme
elle prenait son cheval elle allait à
paris retrouvé tous ses bons copains
ni vu ni connu alors on dirait matin le
faisait une belle java et puis on peut
monter des révoltes on préparait on
astique d'un petit pont faisait monter
la mayonnaise parce que de révolte enfin
monde
une révolte qui porte un nom la fronde
mari et mes deux roues il sera au coeur
avec la duchesse de longueville pour
défendre leurs privilèges face à la
monarchie goûterait dira d'elle que
cette femme est le diable une femme qui
quittera ce monde avec panache faisant
parvenir au roi louis xiv une lettre cyr
il me sera beaucoup pardonné car j'ai
beaucoup aimé ainsi l'âge venu la
sagesse apparu s'est retiré des rondes
que j'écris pour ma tombe ces quelques
qu'elle graf en guise d'épitaphe ci gît
dans une paix profonde une dame de
volupté qui pour plus de sécurité prie
le paradis dans ce monde
[Musique]